Trascrizione: Chiara Carnevali
Revisore: Agnese Giacomelli
Un giorno ho deciso
di dare una svolta alla mia vita.
Sono andata nella stanza di mia madre
e ho indossato un suo vestito.
Era un vestito rosso elegante
e ricordo di aver indossato
anche un paio di scarpe con il tacco.
Erano anch'esse rosse.
Io non avevo mai avuto prima
un paio di scarpe con il tacco.
Mi sono guardata allo specchio
e per la prima volta
ho visto la donna che volevo essere,
quella che volevo diventare nella vita.
Quindi sono andata da mia madre
e le ho detto: “Mamma, me ne vado”.
“Vado a fare la modella”.
E mi sono affrettata a uscire di casa,
lasciandomi alle spalle il suo silenzio.
Purtroppo mia madre mi ha imposto
di rientrare immediatamente
e mi ha riso in faccia,
dicendomi che nessuno
mi avrebbe presa come modella
dal momento che avevo cinque anni.
Mi ci sono voluti anni per capire
l’importanza di questo dettaglio
e soprattutto per capire
che mia madre non fosse cattiva.
Ma fino a quando non sono stata
in grado di comprendere per quale motivo
sia sconsigliabile
che una bambina di 5 anni esca di casa
da sola,
in cerca di qualcuno
che la assuma come modella,
mia madre era definitivamente
la cattiva della mia storia.
Oggi ci raccontiamo tante storie
sui social media.
In realtà noi umani
amiamo raccontarci storie,
soprattutto storie in cui c’è un cattivo,
e c’è un motivo evolutivo
che spiega questa cosa.
Tutto inizia nella preistoria.
Al tempo non si sapeva molto
su come sopravvivere.
Se il tuo amico Abramo veniva da te,
dicendo “Non puoi capire cos’è successo,
Carmelo voleva mangiare un serpente,
ma il serpente l’ha morso e lo ha ucciso”,
questa storia permetteva a te di sapere
che i serpenti fossero pericolosi,
che fossero cattivi.
Così apprendevi dall’esperienza
del povero Carmelo,
senza dovere passare
attraverso le sue stesse esperienze,
senza dover commettere
i suoi stessi errori.
Questi sono, in linea di massima,
i motivi per cui sentiamo il bisogno
di sentirci raccontare
le storie degli altri,
soprattutto quelle in cui c’è un cattivo,
in cui c’è un serpente,
perché è più utile
per la nostra sopravvivenza.
Pensiamo che in questo modo
riusciremo a riconoscere i cattivi,
impareremo a difenderci dai cattivi.
E perché no, non essere
noi stessi i cattivi.
Perché la cattiveria ha un costo,
si paga con il biasimo sociale,
con l’allontanamento dalla comunità.
E questo vale oggi quanto valeva
ai tempi del povero Carmelo.
Quindi questo è uno dei motivi
per cui ci raccontiamo così tante storie,
storie in cui c’è un cattivo.
E va bene fino a quando le storie
che ci raccontiamo sono vere,
sono oneste e i cattivi sono davvero tali.
Ultimamente ha preso piede una tendenza:
noi creiamo il cattivo di sana pianta.
Lo schema è questo.
Succede qualcosa di controverso.
Scoppia uno scandalo
e gli utenti si indignano.
Hanno bisogno di prendersela con qualcuno.
Hanno bisogno di individuare il cattivo,
il serpente da allontanare dalla comunità
per renderla un posto più sicuro.
E succede che a un certo punto
viene individuato un potenziale cattivo,
qualcuno che ha detto o fatto qualcosa
che a qualcun altro non è piaciuto
quindi il suo volto circola sui social,
si solleva una tempesta di insulti
contro questa persona.
Le parole che ha pronunciato
vengono decontestualizzate
e i video in cui compare vengono tagliati
con un abile taglia e cuci
che fa sembrare questa persona
ancora più cattiva.
E si scava nel suo passato
per tirare fuori post infelici,
scritti magari anche dieci anni prima.
L'obiettivo è il boicottaggio.
E la cosa spaventosa è che non importa
che questo cattivo sia effettivamente tale
e non importa che ci sia, magari,
un dettaglio che fa la differenza,
un dettaglio che cambia la prospettiva.
Un dettaglio che stiamo omettendo
dalla narrazione,
ma che ammorbidirebbe
la rabbia degli utenti.
Perché magari quel dettaglio dimostrerebbe
che questa persona non sia cattiva,
ma semplicemente imperfetta.
Etichettare le persone
come buone o cattive
è più semplice dell’analizzare
le sfumature complesse delle loro azioni.
In un mondo sempre più complicato,
semplificare le cose ci offre
un attimo di stabilità, di sicurezza.
Nel dicembre 2021 una giornalista
di nome Greta Beccaglia,
inviata dalla trasmissione
sportiva A tutto gol,
era in diretta con il conduttore
Giorgio Micheletti
e si trovava fuori da uno stadio.
Era lì per commentare
la sconfitta della Fiorentina
e intervistare alcuni tifosi.
All’improvviso un tifoso le si avvicina
e le colpisce il sedere con un ceffone.
Questa cosa accade mentre altri tifosi
intorno a lei la molestano.
La giornalista immediatamente
rimprovera l’aggressore.
Il conduttore le dice con tono preoccupato
“Greta, non te la prendere”.
La giornalista si trova in una situazione
di pericolo, circondata da tifosi ostili.
Ma subito dopo il conduttore, Micheletti,
esprime profonda indignazione
nei confronti di ciò che sta accadendo,
pronunciando queste esatte parole:
“Evidentemente in questo mucchio di tifosi
il quoziente intellettivo è strisciante.
Mi dispiace per i loro genitori.
Si cresce anche attraverso
queste esperienze.
Chiudiamo il collegamento.
Grazie Greta, così perlomeno puoi reagire,
se vuoi, non in diretta,
così ti permettiamo di reagire
perché determinati atteggiamenti meritano,
ogni tanto, qualche sano schiaffone
che se fosse stato dato da piccoli,
probabilmente li avrebbero
fatti crescere più puliti”.
Dopo la fine della puntata,
Micheletti consiglierà alla giornalista
di denunciare l'aggressore.
Questi sono i fatti.
Ma sui social si racconta
una versione molto diversa.
Viene montato ad arte un video
in cui il discorso del conduttore
in difesa della giornalista
viene completamente tagliato,
ad eccezione di due frasi:
“Non te la prendere” e “Si cresce
anche attraverso queste esperienze”.
Il video diventa virale, viene condiviso
da politici di diversi partiti
che condannano non solo il palpeggiatore
ma anche il conduttore
per avere umiliato la giornalista.
Una massa di utenti si scaglia
contro il conduttore,
accusandolo di essersi comportato
in modo peggiore del palpeggiatore
perché avrebbe costretto una donna
a tacere di fronte a una violenza
dicendole “Non te la prendere”,
E avrebbe sminuito l’accaduto
dicendole “Ma sì, si cresce
anche attraverso queste esperienze”.
Il discorso del conduttore Micheletti
è stato imperfetto,
ma non è andata esattamente
come la si racconta.
Eppure il conduttore Micheletti
viene sospeso da Toscana TV.
Il suo discorso è stato manipolato
per renderlo più cattivo,
perché nella storia
che si stava raccontando
il suo personaggio funzionava meglio
nel ruolo del cattivo.
Era più dinamico così,
perché era una storia
di maschi contro femmine.
Qualcuno potrebbe dire
che ciò che è successo a Micheletti
si deve al fatto che sia
un personaggio pubblico.
Ciò che gli è accaduto è il prezzo
da pagare per essere famoso,
per lavorare in televisione.
Questa giustificazione,
se così la vogliamo chiamare,
forse poteva essere avallata
prima dell’avvento dei social media.
Ma la verità è che oggi ciò che è successo
al conduttore Micheletti
può succedere a ognuno di noi.
Basta avere un account sui social media
per avere l’incredibile opportunità
di diventare il cattivo del giorno.
Nell’estate 2023,
è stata molto seguita su Tik Tok
la storia di un’amicizia particolare,
la storia dell’amicizia
tra un ragazzo coreano di nome Jun
e un ragazzo napoletano
noto come Mario Mario.
A un certo punto Jun
è venuto qui in Italia
per incontrare di persona
questo suo grande amico Mario Mario.
Purtroppo però le differenze culturali
hanno preso il sopravvento.
Sono scoppiate delle liti
e Jun ha deciso di andarsene
da casa dell’amico Mario Mario
e andare ad alloggiare
da un’altra amica italiana di nome Elisa.
I fan non hanno accettato, però,
che quest’amicizia potesse finire così,
quindi hanno iniziato a inventare storie
su Elisa e a condividerle su Tik Tok.
Si raccontava che lei costringesse Jun
a rimanere a casa sua
con il ricatto,
quindi contro la sua volontà.
Si diceva che lo avesse derubato
del suo telefono,
che lo avesse derubato dei suoi soldi
e che addirittura lo molestasse.
Questa campagna diffamatoria surreale
si è tradotta in una pioggia
di recensioni negative
sulla pagina del ristorante di Elisa.
Recensioni al limite del bizzarro.
Si diceva che ci fosse un ragazzo coreano
in cantina o legato in bagno.
Qualcun altro diceva che...
[legge i commenti] Ecco.
Qualcun altro diceva che la proprietaria
accettasse solo pagamenti in natura.
Altri si limitavano a riferire
delle scarse condizioni igieniche,
banalmente.
Probabilmente,
nessuno dei reali visitatori della pagina
al tempo poteva lontanamente immaginare
che queste recensioni non fossero reali,
ma che fossero il frutto
di un’allucinazione collettiva.
E tutto ciò non è successo
a un personaggio pubblico.
Non è successo a una celebrità,
ma a una persona comune, una ristoratrice.
Ed è inquietante pensare
che andando in questa direzione,
il prossimo cattivo
potresti essere tu.
Perché tu servi nel ruolo del cattivo
in una storia che ancora non ce l’ha.
E se oggi,
per creare prove che ti inchiodino
nel ruolo del cattivo
bisogna ancora decontestualizzare parole
che comunque hai pronunciato,
ritagliare video in cui comunque
compari realmente,
stiamo procedendo verso un futuro in cui
le prove potranno essere create dal nulla.
Immaginate di potere creare
una foto dal nulla.
Ok, questo è Donald Trump
che viene arrestato dall’FBI.
Queste foto circolano nell’estate 2023
insieme alla notizia
dell’arresto di Donald Trump.
In realtà tutto ciò che state vedendo
non è mai accaduto.
Ma come fare per capire
se si tratta di una foto reale
o generata da un’intelligenza artificiale?
Perché queste sono foto generate
da un’intelligenza artificiale.
Attenzione, non sono fotomontaggi
che hanno richiesto ore di lavoro
da parte di un professionista.
Sono immagini che sono state realizzate
con poco più di un clic.
Oggi, per capire se una foto
sia reale o falsa,
bisogna cercare nei dettagli.
Osservando questa foto potete
notare delle distorsioni
– non so se riuscite a vederle –
nella mano di Donald Trump.
Questo perché le IA non sono ancora capaci
di riprodurre le mani in modo accurato.
Questa dovrebbe essere
la foto segnaletica di Donald Trump,
ma i numeri dietro di lui non hanno senso
e alcuni addirittura sono capovolti.
Questa è fake.
Perché sì.
(Risate)
Imperfezioni, perché le intelligenze
artificiali ancora sono immature,
sono inesperte.
Ma con questo strumento
possiamo già creare prove
che documentino eventi
che non sono mai accaduti.
Con questo strumento un giorno, in futuro,
potremo creare una serie di foto
del conduttore Giorgio Micheletti
intento a palpeggiare una donna
o foto del ristorante di Elisa,
sporco, pieno di scarafaggi
da allegare a una recensione negativa.
E ci sarà un momento
in cui qualcuno si chiederà,
“Ma perché dovrei pensare
che queste foto siano false e non vere?”
Ecco, quello sarà il momento
in cui i dettagli ci proteggeranno.
Un dettaglio potrebbe fare la differenza
nella storia che si racconta di te
e per questo sarebbe importante
educare le masse a cercarli, i dettagli,
a scrostare la superficie
di quello che vedono e leggono sui social.
E l'ideale sarebbe farlo nei luoghi
che sono adibiti all'educazione.
Le scuole, per esempio.
Quando andavo a scuola
odiavo le verifiche in classe
e non perché fossi impreparata, di solito.
Le odiavo perché, nella maggior parte
delle materie umanistiche,
c’era un limite nella consegna.
La consegna suonava pressappoco così:
“Rispondi alle seguenti domande
in non più di dieci righe”.
La cosa sarebbe stata accettabile
se i quesiti fossero stati formulati così:
“Quando è nato Van Gogh?”
e io avrei risposto con la data
di nascita di Van Gogh e basta.
Sarei andata avanti con la mia vita.
Ma le domande erano formulate così:
“Parla della Notte Stellata di Van Gogh,
inserendo riferimenti
alla biografia dell’artista,
contestualizzando il periodo
storico in cui visse Van Gogh
e analizzando le differenze tra l’arte
di Van Gogh e quella di Renato Zero
in massimo dieci righe.”
Per me era un incubo.
Più avevo studiato e più era un incubo.
Ricordo che l’insegnante mi diceva,
“devi scrivere solo le cose importanti”
e io non capivo quali fossero
le informazioni importanti,
perché nella mia percezione
tutte si influenzavano l’una con l’altra.
E quindi avevo l’impressione
che se avessi omesso un solo dettaglio
di cui ero a conoscenza,
avrei potuto offendere in qualche modo
la memoria di un personaggio storico.
E quindi scrivevo e tagliavo, cancellavo,
e arrivavo allo scadere del tempo
che ancora non avevo finito
di rispondere alla prima domanda.
Finita la scuola pensavo che la condanna
alla sintesi fosse finita.
Mi sbagliavo, perché all’università
la storia si è ripetuta.
Un giorno mi sono ritrovata a dover
selezionare una materia a scelta
e ho scelto letteratura moderna.
Ho seguito le lezioni,
ho studiato tutto il programma
e sono arrivata viva
al giorno della simulazione
– perché questo professore ci faceva fare
le simulazioni dell’esame,
che era un esame scritto –
e la consegna era questa:
“Rispondi alle seguenti domande
in non più di dieci righe”.
Di nuovo.
E ancora ricordo la prima domanda.
“Di cosa parla il romanzo
‘I Promessi Sposi’?“.
Ho cambiato materia a scelta
dopo avere studiato tutto il programma
e ho perso sei mesi di università.
Non me ne pento.
Il mio professore sosteneva
che fosse importante
coltivare il dono della sintesi.
Ma se anche la scuola e l’università
si mettono a dispensare la lezione
che la superficialità sul luogo di lavoro,
quale dovrebbe essere l’università,
sia un’abilità
invece di fare il contrario,
invece di incoraggiare l’approfondimento,
invece di premiare
la ricerca indipendente,
perché dovremmo aspettarci
che sui social, il luogo del tempo libero,
gli utenti si comportino
come i cercatori di verità?
Ora.
In questa storia il mio professore
di letteratura moderna
sembra un po’ il cattivo della storia.
Ma c'è un dettaglio che
cambia la prospettiva.
Purtroppo però il mio tempo
sta per scadere.
Anzi vi dico la verità,
già è scaduto da 4 minuti,
quindi sono costretta a raccontarvi
questa storia in breve,
in non più di dieci righe.
Non me ne voglia il mio professore
se passiamo direttamente alle conclusioni.
Il punto è questo: un giorno tu potresti
essere il cattivo della storia.
Quel giorno vorrai che se c’è un dettaglio
che cambia la prospettiva,
che fa la differenza,
non venga omesso dalla narrazione.
Ma in realtà si raccontano già
tante storie su di te,
i tuoi amici, i tuoi ex amici,
i tuoi colleghi di lavoro,
i tuoi parenti, soprattutto,
parlano di te.
E stai sereno che nei loro racconti
tu sei buono o cattivo.
Tutti i dettagli che ti rendono
semplicemente umano vengono sorvolati.
Tu sei il serpente che ha ucciso Carmelo,
oppure sei il povero Carmelo.
E probabilmente tu fai lo stesso con loro,
quindi hai continuamente l’occasione
per esercitarti a cambiare prospettiva.
Ecco, ogni volta che stai per etichettare
qualcuno come cattivo,
ricordati che nella storia del serpente
la sua è stata legittima difesa.
Grazie.
(Applausi)